في سكاي سبورتس تجربة المدينة الملكية
يكفي في الأدلة المتوقعة عليهم
تحويل Wortberg الفردية
معًا في أكبر موقع مفتوح في العالم
مهمة جوية
لكن المزيج هو مشروع فريد من نوعه
مؤشر العناية
اسمي هو o Care sanmiguel أكرس نفسي
لتحويل المساحات حول العالم
قبل كل شيء لتغيير الأسمنت الرمادي
لون
مثل الرسم ومساعدتي
رسم اللوحة الجدارية فجأة لدى الكثير
تعلمت التواصل من خلال
الفن رائع
[موسيقى]
على الجانب تحويله إلى نوع
من وعالمية حيث الجميع
تستوعب جميع الأديان
سباق بين الجنسين
نبيع سكارفيس الأهم
بالنسبة لي في هذا المشروع هو
التجربة الشخصية التي آخذها معي
كل ذلك لأن صنع الفن أمر جيد جدًا
الفن حقا هو الإرسال
مشاعر أو أحاسيس للناس أو
تكون جماليات الشعور ولكن نعم
يغير حياة شخص ما
فقط كن واحدًا أعتقد أنه مستوى بالفعل
أعلى
[موسيقى]